So,
when I select that sentence, I realize that I am a knight who protects the princess of this country.I know it's a
text-to-speech app.It
's an app that reads out the characters you type in in advance using an electronic voice.I
never thought I'd read the text from that book.  Ai-kun took the trouble to
type everything into his smartphone by hand.The way we
talked until now, Mr. Yoshimoto and the
person being talked to had to look at a book, so we couldn't look each other in the eye when we talked.But with
this app.  By using this, you can look people in the eye and have a
conversation.There's no way that I can
understand how difficult it is for Mr. Yoshimoto to speak, and I ca
n't
tell him that I'll do my best to become better at speaking, so I'm just going to talk like
this, even just a little bit.  I wish I could help you
communicate with people more easily.
Try it out and say something to me. I
love you
[Music]
OG